♪ ♪
>> Bret: WELCOME BACK TO A
WINDY WHITE HOUSE.
IMMIGRATION WILL BE A BIG FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL IS ON
CAPITOL HILL TO TELL US WHERE WE
ARE NOW ON IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> I WANT THE RESOLVE FROM THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE A DECISION.
NOT.
>> DREAMERS, YOUNG PEOPLE
BROUGHT TO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
BY THEIR PARENTS, WANT
REASSURANCE FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
REASSURANCE FROM PRESIDENT TRUM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS ARE
TELLING THEM THEY ARE HERE TO
NOT ONLY OVERWHELMINGLY IN THE
COUNTRY BUT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE CONGRESS.
WE WILL NOT STOP.
IT WILL NOT END EXCEPT HAPPILY
FOR OUR DREAMERS.
>> REPUBLICANS QUESTION WHETHER
PELOSI AND DEMOCRATS WANT A
SOLUTION OR WOULD PREFER TO HAVE
THE ISSUE IN THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE A
SERIOUS OFFER ON DACA WHICH THE
MAJORITY LEADER SETS HAS SOME
LEADERS WHO HAVE SAID WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS OFFERED AS A
REASONABLE PROPOSAL.
IT OUGHT TO BREAK THE ICE, GIVE
EMPHASIZED A DEAL.
>> YOU HAVE TO SECURE THE
BORDER, START BUILDING THE WALL
COME UP WITH THE TECHNOLOGY AND
TOOLS IN PLACE.
>> SPEAKER PAUL RYAN RAISE THE
CONCERN THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SUCH AS SPENDING CAPS AND
DO THE RIGHT THING.
DROP THE FILIBUSTER, PROCESS
LEGISLATION.
WE WANT TO FIND A DACA SOLUTION.
>> THERE HAS BEEN SOME QUESTION
SENIOR G.O.P. LEADERS THEY HAVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP VAX A PARTICULAR